hey guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
cj by whoopty cj whoopty i don't i've
never heard of it but someone in my life
requested that i do it so don't forget
to subscribe to my channel i want to
move out of my parents house
at some point it would be nice and
comment what song i should do next so
i'm about to
all right let's let's go i'm ready to be
cool
[Music]
he said something important here he's
addicted to blue cheese
and i'm kind of excited because i don't
think blue cheese
gets the credit that it deserves like
honestly
it is so good i'm just glad like someone
can appreciate it
two second observation got a lot of
friends
everyone in these videos just has hell
of friends i don't get it
i don't have that many friends but i'm
gonna keep going i'm gonna keep going to
this paper like loosely [ __ ] i'm by my
chicken like it's a two piece you gotta
have your [ __ ]
[Music]
okay okay i got it i got it so he said
she swallowed my kids so that's like a
i don't know can i say that on youtube a
[ __ ] um
so he gets girls that's what he's trying
to say like i get girls
i'm cool like that's what i got in the
trap
[Music]
okay it's a lot of like talking about a
girl
so i don't know if like this is like
multiple girls because he said he's like
blowing her back out
so like he's like hooking up like i
think the whole point of the song so far
is like i get girls and i'm cool
also has a really cool car a lot of
friends um
i'm trying to think i really like the
beat of this song
honestly like i've never found a song
that i like to beat up
as much like that's what i like right
now it's like
i feel like i can like bounce you know
like
bump in okay when i see police then we
getting low that's another piece that's
another zone
icing the vvs now she down to get treaty
i got all this water on me like fiji
[ __ ] i'm posted up with hats in the
sleazies
[Music]
like first he says when they see the
police
like ducking so they're they're doing
some illegal activities i don't know
what
i'm not gonna point fingers i just i
feel like they're doing something
illegal here
this dog is so cute i think it was a
good move on them to bring the dog
blue cheese i swear i'm addicted to the
blue cheese i gotta stick to this paper
like loosely bitching by my chicken like
it's a two piece you can have your [ __ ]
back she a groupie she just swallow all
my kids in a two seat
oh okay i get it i get it so he's saying
like your girl is a groupie like i'm so
famous
that like your girl could like
like she wants me because i'm like cool
and famous
swagged out familiar we bringing them
gas out i still got some racks stuck in
the trap house off the 42 i'm blowing
her back out
i'm back i'm [ __ ] it's been back
with a full clip they say i'm moving out
[Music]
um i like like that out of all the songs
i've listened to
i don't think the lyrics were the best i
liked the i forgot what the
i never remember the names of these
songs i liked different ones that told
more of a story but i thought this one
is like catchy
like if i was in a bar i would shimmy to
it you know what i mean
so i liked that he brought up blue
cheese
i think he's just saying like i got a
lot of friends and
i can get girls and i'm cool pretty
simple song
if you liked that video don't forget to
subscribe subscribe subscribe
again trying to move out of my parents
house everyone's praying for the day
and don't forget comment what video i
should do next